Taman recently returned to the studio
with her producer Adam Barda to record
her new hit song moneymaker oh there's a
news the follow-up single to her hit
free to be me first I want to take you
through the recording process we sent
surely our own Shirley down through
record tan mom in this studio tan mom
had some trouble even getting to the
recording studio she canceled 30 minutes
before the first session she canceled
the first thing cuz studio time costs
you know cost money says she was sick
sick and the next day she showed up an
hour early so nobody was there to letter
it and was she pissed yeah where is
everyone
she went from sweet voice Patricia to
angry Tammy hey mom looks at this song
as a new chapter in her life I want to
hear you do some of these lines here
wait I'm gonna rock it don't stop at one
point it says here Tam mom had no idea
who her producer was or what he did
right it's not just at one point this is
three hours into the session she's like
who are you I'm sorry what do you do
again it must be so much fun to be with
her it is AB like at one point I find
that exhausting she goes on her back
like she drops down from the window in
the booth I don't know where she went
there's an elevator there's and I walk
around the corner and I see she's laying
on her back and she has her legs over
her head yeah and I walk in I go
Patricia are you okay
and her her throats being squished on
her voice sound she goes
[Laughter]